so like how long do you for example like
think you could like
keep doing youtube or like how how long
like because because i
because you know i think everything you
should ride or you've got a plan yeah is
that like because i think every youtuber
gets asked the question like oh where do
you see yourself in five years ten years
like that kind of stuff right which i
think is the stupidest question ever i
guess
it's hard to kind of i guess what feels
right you know just go with the win
because i definitely don't feel like
doing i'm i'm trying to like i have
plans to make my channel
not just hentai focused anymore i want
to show off some of my other talents you
know
voice work maybe if i'm talented but um
are just like other things that i'm like
that are interesting in the anime spear
uh i don't cause you've done like a few
videos where you like go to you know
bars that are
yeah that are featured in manga yeah and
honestly i really like
i honestly really love those videos i i
guess just seeing just
me out and about you know do you feel
like you got drawn into just making
content about hentai just because of you
saw how well it was doing
did you feel pressure about it or of
course of course i feel pressure about
it
believe it or not do i always want to
make content just about hentai of course
not
i it just gets the clicks yeah it just
gets the like
of course i enjoy it and i wouldn't be
making anything i think it's just
further views for me because like
that at any time
here's like a little trade secret that
i'm just gonna spill right now
like some of sydney's videos uh some of
cindy's videos ideas have been ideas
that i've pitched to her
because sometimes i get ideas
sometimes i get ideas and i'm like i
can't do this for my channel
but like i live vicariously through
sydney to be like yo sydney i can't i
can't do this idea for my channel
can you like can you like do it can you
do me a good one do it
yeah because i remember the the one like
the wonder jinxie i wanted to like
uh get someone to talk about was uh
retake which
going back to the fan fiction thing i
was talking about earlier like this this
is the
this is the dojinshi that got me into
thinking hey
maybe fan fictions aren't that bad
because this is rita
retake to explain to you is basically
just
a entire [ __ ] retelling of the end of
evangelion
because i remember i first when i first
watched the end of evangelion as a kid
and i'm talking about the movie it is
not
a satisfying conclusion if you don't
understand what's happening
and especially like i i have a deeper
appreciation of end of ava now
as an adult but as a kid i'm just like i
just wanna i just wanna see what happens
and then through that i discovered
retake
and retake is retake is one of the most
satisfying fan fictions i have ever read
where it kind of ties up
every loose end that i wanted to be tied
up
in when i was watching the original ava
and it gave me the same kind of
conclusion and satisfaction within
myself that i would have felt
even if it was just a canon like in my
head it is kind of just canon
i watched your video about it yeah
that's the reason why i know it exists
yeah yeah because guarantee like
and then i got to read it yeah like we
actually had to watch evangelion first
because i never really watched
evangelion probably till recently
and then he showed me retake and we
shared the exact same opinions on it
like so you know that's true
we came at the exact same phrase
oh my god you skipped the [ __ ] too
same
and i'm like yo yo sydney why don't you
make a video about this
oh my god sydney why don't you make a
video though
and so you did that's what i did
i might be honest i'm like his little
entertainer and he's my agent but we
have like a little like sexy
relationship
pouring on the way you didn't you really
didn't have to sleep
you're really going to do me like this
sydney all right
all i ask is what are you doing
oh my god yeah is there anything else
you want to mention or anything
else you want to talk about what the
that's a
anything you want me to pretend to like
ask you about
you want to tell just ask like what jobs
did i have previously what jobs did you
appreciate i'm curious
mcdonald's cool thank you
i don't know if you're actually asking
okay yeah we're actually okay
well when i was in high school my first
job was at a frozen yogurt place
and then i started i moved to england
and that's the widest thing you've ever
said
is that you're gonna elaborate more on
the frozen yogurt store
very long did anything happen how long
were you there for uh
four or five months and then off the
internet and then i graduated high
school
and then i started working at a bakery
at a supermarket
no way i know before i graduated high
school supermarket bakery
and then i moved to england and i
started working at weatherspoons
worst job i've ever had i hated it it's
if you guys don't know what
weatherspoons is it's this cheap i think
you guys might have
yeah we mentioned it um the old people
there would start at like 8 a.m
they'd always come in with like the
first thing they'd always order is shots
of like whiskey or vodka and they just
keep going all old british people are
like i don't know what's wrong man
they always go to the pub at like 9 00
am yeah to meet up with them
to meet up with their other old friends
and they just get drunk that's all they
do
and they were mean they were mean they'd
always be like like they'd be like you
shouldn't be in our country
you're not like they were pretty mean
yeah
i know i screamed yeah i'd be screamed
at every day
and it's like sometimes i'd cry and
they'd be like oh now you're just trying
to make me feel bad and i was like you
just told me to like you just call me a
[ __ ]
yeah and like sometimes i pour a beer or
like not because
i didn't really like know how to pour
beer pouring a pint is a very
strict procedure yeah and they're just
like you dumb [ __ ] like
they would an old british man would call
you a dumb [ __ ]
no way i refused to call me a [ __ ] like
a [ __ ] i could see a bit of dumb [ __ ]
[ __ ] i can see but dumb [ __ ] nah
that's that's too
fast that happens